hello everyone and welcome to my talk on
transforming data to unlock its latent
value I'd like to start off here by
asking you guys a few questions so first
how many of you consider yourselves data
scientists
okay great how many of you spend a lot
of time exploring data in your day to
day work okay excellent now how many of
you have a formal process or framework
that you use specifically for data
exploration perfect so so what I'd like
to do in this talk is tell you a little
bit about the process that I use for
exploratory data analysis in my day to
day work and so for those of you the few
of you that already have a process of
your own my hope is that you see some
similarities in our approaches and maybe
take away a couple things that you can
add to your own process and for most of
you who don't what I hope is that you
take away from this talk and intuitive
repeatable framework for analyzing
visualizing and discovering insights
from your data but before I jump into
that I'd like to tell you a little bit
about myself
here so that's me I'm Tony Ojeda I've
been in the analytics space and more
recently in the data science space for
over a decade now I'm the founder of
district data labs which is a science
education and research company based in
Washington DC and I got into data
science from a business analytics and
Finance background which is kind of
where I acquired my quantitative skills
and then I taught myself at a program
over the years in both R and Python and
so in the years that I've been in this
field I've worked with my fair share of
analysts data scientists as well as
students looking to learn data science
and I've noticed that particularly
during a data exploration phase of their
work I often see them grasping at straws
when it comes to their approach to
finding insights and data and so what I
wanted to do was put this presentation
together to help create a more
structured path that people could follow
so that they could view insight
discovery as a problem break that
problem down into manageable components
and then start working towards a
solution and so in this talk we're going
to look at
an example of a real data set I'm going
to introduce you to the framework that I
use and then I'm gonna walk you through
applying those concepts from that
framework to that example data set but
before I jump right into that I'd like
to talk a little bit about how I think
about data and provide a little bit of
context so data is essentially encoded
information and the world that we live
in is a very complex web of it each of
us has a ton of information and details
floating around in our heads there's
constantly new information coming in and
things are constantly changing and so as
humans we have this ability and this
capacity to deal with all this
complexity and all this information that
we're constantly receiving and the way
that we do that is by putting things in
order we group things into categories we
create hierarchical classifications
taxonomy x' ontology x' all of these
things and these things help to provide
order and structure to the way we view
the world around us and they allow us to
look at something recognize the
similarities it has to a group of other
things quickly identify some of its
properties and then be able to make some
decisions about it
and in fact if we think about it a data
set all it really is is just slice of
this complex information that somebody
has put together to try to communicate
something about this complex world to a
human or to a machine and so the fact
that this ability is built into us is
great right and we use it all the time
without ever really thinking about it
and that includes unfortunately we're
analyzing our data so I wanted to put
together data exploration framework that
leveraged this ability that we have and
that would help us make better use of
this ability in our science workflows
and so here is the framework that I came
up with
it's basically broken down into two
phases there's the prep phase first and
then the exploration phase that comes
after that and you can think of the prep
phase kind of as a ritual you can
technically do the explore phase without
it but it's the prep phase that's going
to allow you to do the exploration
so I highly recommend that you do that
and I'm gonna be walking through this
framework here for the rest of the
presentation so the data set that I'm
gonna be applying this framework to
today is the Environmental Protection
Agency's fuel economy data set and this
is what it looks like after some light
cleanup I've also included the URL on
here where you can get the data set
yourself if you wanted to and so the
first step in the in the prep part of
framework is to identify a couple of
things about our data first is going to
be to identify the types of information
that we have in the data set and so
taking a look at this data there's a few
things that there's a few of these types
of information that are kind of obvious
they they jump right out at us
there's vehicle attribute information
there's vehicle manufacturer information
engine information fuel information
transmission information that kind of
stuff there's also some other types of
information that may not be so obvious
and so because we have the year that
that each of the vehicles was made we
should be able to see changes in the
data over time we also have relationship
data in our data set both in terms of
the relationships between fields and
relationships between entities and our
data and finally because we have both
time and relationship information in
there we can acquire information about
how those relationships have changed
over time the next step here was to
identify the actual entities that are in
our data and so what exactly do I mean
by entities when I refer to an entity
I'm talking about the individual
analyzable units that are in a data set
and so in order to conduct analysis on
the data the entities must be
distinguishable from one another right a
human or a machine needs to be able to
take a look at them and say this is one
this is another this is another and
finally entities usually have a
hierarchical structure whether they're
able to be aggregated into a system or a
higher level
they belong to and so let's take a look
at some examples of entities that are in
this particular data set here to kind of
try to drive this concept home so we're
starting off at level one here which is
the most granular that we have it's the
year and the specific model of the
vehicle at level two we can aggregate
that up to just the year and the model
type which is a little bit less granular
and from there we can we have a few
different directions that we can go we
can go the year and the vehicle class
the year in the math or just strip away
the year and just keep the model type
and then at level four if we want to
continue going we have just the vehicle
classes the years or all the makes and
so to drive this moment and make this a
little clearer here are some like
concrete examples of actual records that
are in the dataset so at level one we're
talking about a 2016 Ford Mustang 2.3
liter v4 engine automatic transmission
rear-wheel drive right so very detailed
at level two we're rolling that up to
say okay all 2016 Ford Mustangs and then
so forth and so on up the hierarchy
there and and again doing this is
important and it'll help you think about
all the different things that you can do
to the data and the different ways you
can look at it later on I see a lot of
people that are new to data science that
don't do this they don't think like this
and so they miss things in the data that
they really should be caching so I hope
that this example makes it a little bit
clearer the next step in the praise in
the prep phase here is to review some
transformation and some of the
visualization methods that we have
available to us so that they're fresh in
our heads and so first up I have here
the transformation methods and so the
first one I have listed here is is
filtering which is basically taking the
data set and making it smaller by either
looking at less rows or less columns or
both the next one is aggregation and
disaggregation and this is where you're
changing the levels that we look
before that you're analyzing the data at
getting either more or less granular
after that we have pivoting which is
where you aggregate by more than one
variable at a time so along each each of
the axes so the rows and the columns
each have a variable and then you look
at some count or some average or
something like that and how those are
grouped and then the last one I have
listed on here is graph transformations
which is where you link the entities
you're analyzing by the things they have
in common and then you examine the
connections between the entities and how
they're related to each other and so by
transforming the data you're altering
the structure of it right which lets you
look at it from from several different
perspectives and just like looking at
anything else from a bunch of different
perspectives you're gonna learn
something new about it from every way
that you look at it and the awesome
thing about this is that the number of
ways that you can transform the data is
only limited by your creativity
essentially and so this for me is one of
the most exciting things about working
with data all the different things that
you can do to it and all the creative
ways that you can transform it in
addition to transforming the data I also
like to go step further and visualize it
sometimes the transformations that you
perform kind of in the earlier step can
be kind of difficult to look at and
interpret visually and plotting them
really allows you to pull in the human
visual cortex into your analytical
process and makes the insights really
jump right out at you and transformation
and visualization really go hand in hand
since there's a multitude of ways to
transform data there's also a multitude
of ways to visualize it as well and so
here I've listed a few of these and
there'll be additional pictures later on
in the presentation if you're not
familiar with a few of these all right
and so the last step in the prep phase
is to create some additional categorical
fields that are going to make our data
easier to transform and explore later on
and we're going to do this
three ways so the first way that we're
going to do this is by identifying
opportunities to create higher level
categories out of the current categories
that we have in our data so I have an
example up here so imagine that you're
aggregating by transmission this dataset
has 44 unique categories for the Tran
transmission field and so that's gonna
be tough to look at and you're gonna
have to work really hard to find
insights there but uh if we take a look
at the different categories that are in
this and we're able to find some things
that they have in common then we can
make it a lot easier on ourselves so in
this case the thing that all 44 values
here have in common is that they either
fall into an automatic transmission
category or a manual transmission
category and so we've created a new
field called transmission type that just
has whether that record falls into one
of those two categories the same thing
for the vehicle class is just another
example this one has 34 unique
categories in that categorical variable
field and I was able to distill those
down into eight categories that are
listed here on the slide and so that
makes things a little more manageable
and so keep in mind that you're not over
writing the original categories you're
just creating another categorical field
that's allowing you to view the
information at a higher level and so if
you need to drill down to get more
granular categories you can always do
that but at least after you do this you
actually have the option the next way
that we can create additional categories
for ourselves is by pinning some of the
continuous variables and breaking them
up into different categories based on
how high or how low they are there's
multiple ways that you can do this but I
like to use quintiles because it gives
me kind of one moderate category in the
middle and then two categories outside
of that that are kind of moderately
higher and lower and then two other
categories at the ends that are kind of
more extreme and I just find it that's a
very intuitive way to to split
and so I've identified four fields in
the data set here on the slide that we
can do this for in the current data set
and then the final thing we're going to
do in the prep phase here is cluster our
data and create different categories out
of the different clusters that result
from that and now there's there's a few
reasons that I like to use clustering to
create categories like this the first is
that it takes multiple fields into
consideration together at the same time
whereas the other categorization
approaches we we were looking at earlier
only consider one field at a time
it also creates some new categories for
you automatically which is great because
it it saves time versus you having to
comb through the data yourself trying to
identify any patterns and form
categories based off of that
the third reason I like clustering is
because it sometimes groups things in
ways that you as a human may not may not
have thought of yourself and I'm a big
fan of kind of humans and-and-and
machines working together on stuff like
this but the question with clustering is
always well how many clusters do I use
and the answer is usually it depends
there's no real right answer for this
now that being said I personally try to
keep it to under ten clusters when I'm
doing this for creating categories
because otherwise it becomes too many
categories for you to intuitively try to
distinguish between and so I usually
start out with about eight or ten
clusters and then I try to work my way
down until I find some clear boundaries
between the clusters so you should be
able to look at them and visually
distinguish one from the other and so
starting out that's going to look like
this so just from looking at this you
can tell that we probably have too many
clusters here because clusters three
four and six look a lot alike clusters
zero and one are also pretty close to
each other and clusters two and five
also look a lot alike as well and so
just judging from the way this looks I'm
willing to bet that we can cut the
number of clusters in half
and get some better distinct
distinctions between each of the
clusters so let's go ahead and do that
and so now here we've reduced the number
of clusters to four and now the clusters
look a lot better right clusters 0 and 1
look like polar opposites of each other
cluster 2 looks like it's pretty well
balanced all across the board and
consider 3 looks like it's kind of
halfway between clusters 0 and cluster 2
and so now that we have a good number of
clusters that's great but it's kind of
hard to remember what clusters 0 1 2 & 3
mean right and so the next thing I like
to do is I to assign some descriptive
names to the clusters based on kind of
how how low or how high each of the
values were each of the boxes so for our
data set I'm gonna assign each of the
clusters the names that I have on the
slide here and now we have these
meaningful categories and now our data
is in really good shape and that means
that we can move on to the explore phase
so in the explore phase we're first
going to look at filtering and
aggregation and then we're going to look
at the relationships between fields and
then the relationships between entities
and we're going to look at these things
visually we're gonna look at these
things over time and we're going to use
them to discover insights in our data
and so here I filtered the data by year
so just for 2016 and I've a graded it by
vehicle category which was one of the
eight categories that we created earlier
and so this is what the data
transformation looks like as well as the
corresponding bar chart and so from this
we can see that small cards there's
significantly more of them than all the
other types of vehicles SUVs are kind of
the next most popular follows followed
by the midsize cars and so once you've
done this it's very easy to change out
either the year or the category that
you're aggregating on to get a different
perspective on the data
so here I've changed out the year and at
aggregated on
same category and so here you'll you'll
notice that SUVs didn't exist yet small
cars were even more popular and pickup
trucks were as well and so in addition
to changing the year as I mentioned you
can also change out the field that
you're grouping on right so here going
back to 2016 here I've changed out the
vehicle category for the engine size
quintiles that we created earlier here's
the fuel of the fuel efficiency
quintiles that we created earlier and
even our our clusters and this is great
but what if we wanted to take a look at
the vehicle manufacturers let's say that
we wanted to know how many models each
manufacturer currently makes or even
which manufacturer currently makes the
most right we can do that pretty easily
as well just change out the make for
whatever the category that you had in
there was and so here we can see that
BMW currently has more models on the
market than at any other auto
manufacturer and by quite a bit actually
okay so so so far we've been looking at
the data at a pretty high level we've
been aggregating by a single categorical
variable at a time next we're going to
go down a level and take a look at two
or more variables at a time and the way
that we do that is with pivot tables so
here I've created a pivot table heat map
where you have a row for each fuel
efficiency category and a column for
each engine size category and you can
see how many vehicles fall into each
combination of these and just like we
did earlier we can slice by a different
year and easily get a different
perspective right so here's what the
same heat map looks like for 1985 right
2016 1985 and with this approach we're
not just limited to two variables we can
have multiple variables for each of the
axes and it'll show us all the different
combinations of values for those
variables by whatever other variables we
want and so in this next heat map I've
basically
doubled up on the rose so we've got it
engine size and fuel efficiency
combinations represented by the rose and
we've added a third variable which is
the vehicle category across each of the
columns and so now we can see a finer
level of detail about what types of cars
of what size engines at what level of
fuel efficiency we've we've added a
little bit more complexity and a little
bit more granularity to how we're
viewing the data here and so if we want
to go back to analyzing the different
auto manufacturers what we can do is we
can take a look at how the number of
models they have on the market currently
is distributed across all the different
vehicle categories and so that's exactly
what I've done here and now you can get
a better sense of each auto company's
current strategy in terms of the breadth
versus the depth of vehicles that they
currently offer so it looks like BMWs
doubling down on small cars as is
Porsche of Ford and Chevy and Nissan are
going for breadth right they make
vehicles in just about every category
Jeep and Land Rover are basically only
creating SUVs Rams only creating pickup
trucks and so forth and so on and so in
addition to looking at these different
aggregations and pivots visually at a
given point in time I also find it
insightful to take a look at how they've
changed over time and so for example
here are our vehicle categories just
aggregated but over time now so we can
see that small cars have generally
dominated all across the board we can
see the introduction and increase in
popularity of SUVs starting in the late
90s and we can also see the gradual
decline in popularity of of pickup
trucks which is the blue line on the
graph here and if we wanted to we can
zoom in and do a filter for a specific
manufacturer in order to see how their
specific strategy has changed over the
years and so here's BMWs vehicle
categories
over time you'll recall from a previous
graph that they had a bunch of more
vehicles and all the other companies
current currently specifically in small
cars category so here we're able to see
kind of the evolution of that right so
they started off making a reasonable
amount of small cars and then sometime
in the late 90s they made a decision to
increase the types of small cars that
they make and we can contrast that with
a company like Toyota where it's kind of
the opposite they started off making a
bunch of small cars and then they made a
decision to make fewer and fewer of them
over the years
instead shifting their focus to SUVs
pickup trucks and midsize cars all right
so the next step in the explore phase
here is examining the relationships
between filled in the data so if we're
looking at relationships between
variables I like to start off with a
scatter matrix which looks kind of like
this and this gives me a bird's eye view
of the relationships between all the
fields in my data set so from this we
can see that there's some linear
relationships and there are some more
exponential ones in there as well and
this is great but what's even better is
that we can add another dimension of
insight to this by overlaying a layer of
color on top of this that represents one
of our other categorical variables and
so here I've overlaid the clusters that
we came up with earlier and now we can
see not only the relationships but also
the different cluster the different
clusters and where their boundaries are
and how much overlap there is from one
cluster to the next and once you've got
this colorful bird's-eye view we can
easily zoom in on anything that we think
looks interesting and so here at zoomed
in on the engine size versus the fuel
efficiency to see kind of how those are
related and I've got the cluster overlay
in here and so you'll see kind of at the
upper-left here you have your your
smaller more efficient engine vehicles
and then in the blue
you've got your smaller kind of more
moderately efficient vehicles in the red
you've got your mid-sized more balanced
vehicles and then at the bottom right
you've got your larger more less
fuel-efficient cars and we can do the
same thing with the engine size and the
fuel cost so taking a look here at a
more linear relationship with the
clusters and you kind of see the cluster
boundaries on here as well this time
going from the bottom left up to the
upper right and again you can do it for
any combination of variables that you
have in the data set these are just a
couple of examples all right so the
third step and our explore phase here is
examining the relationships between the
entities in our data and the way that
we're going to do that is through graph
analysis so as I said before graph
analysis is going to allow us to explore
relationships between these entities and
these relationships are you are usually
based on attributes that the entities
have in common or actions that one
entity takes that involves another and
so the entities we're going to be
analyzing here in this example or the
auto manufacturers again and in this
case the attributes that they have in
common are going to be the vehicles that
have similar attributes to each other so
we're gonna examine how the different
manufacturers relate to each other and
how those relationships have changed
over time as well in order to do this
we're gonna have to transform our data
set again from the relational form it's
currently in here into graph form and
that looks kind of like this so we have
two different companies as make X and
make Y and then we have an edge weight
and this edge weight tells us how many
vehicles with similar attributes the two
companies have in common so the more
vehicles with similar attributes they
have in common the more alike the two
companies are and the stronger their
connection is going to be and so looking
at the data in this format you might say
well there's not much to this and you're
right but having it formatted like this
to create really interesting things like
this so this is a network visualization
showing the relationships of all the
different vehicle manufacturers to each
other and from taking a look at this we
can see for example that the companies
that make the most types of vehicles I'm
across the most number of categories are
positioned towards the center of the
network here and that's because they're
gonna have more in common with other
companies just as a result of the depth
and the breadth of their offerings you
can contrast that with the companies
that have more specialized offerings
like Ram at the very top there or Land
Rover at the bottom these companies make
only one kind of vehicle so they have
less connections in their position near
kind of the edges of the network and so
this is great
but looking at all this at once does
kind of make it look a little cluttered
so what I usually like to do from here
is try to filter down and look at an ego
graph for a specific auto manufacturer
so here we have an ego graph for Nissan
and you can basically see here that
they're now at the center of the network
and you can also see all the other
companies that are that they have
vehicles in common with and how they're
connected to each other so that's an
interesting way to kind of zoom in and
view on a graph
another thing that that you can do with
graphs is community detection and so I
took our original graph and I ran it
through a community detection algorithm
and it was able to find four communities
in our graph and what I've done here is
I've basically color-coded the notes in
the graph by the community that they
belong to and then you probably guess
what's coming up next and that's taking
a look at how the connections in our
graph have changed over time
so here I have a line graph that shows
the number of edges or connections for
each of the manufacturers and when you
have a lot of nodes in the graph this
tends to look a bit cluttered as well
but as we did before we can
we fix this by zooming in and being able
to filter on a specific make that were
interested in and that's exactly what
I've done here so here I've chosen just
a handful of companies and now we can
see more clearly how each of their
connections have changed over time how
they started off kind of spread out and
they've converged
over time alright so we've done a lot
this dataset using just a few concepts
and so let's do a quick recap here's an
image of the framework again so we
started off with the prep phase we
identified the types of information that
we're in our data set we identified the
entities that were in our data set as
well and then we did a review of all the
different transformation and
visualization things that we could do to
our data set from there we created
additional categories that we're going
to help us down in the explore phase so
we did that through category
aggregations through pinning our
continuous variables and through
clustering and then we moved on to the
explore phase where we started with the
filtering in the aggregating and then we
looked at field relationships and then
we looked at the relationships between
entities here at the end and we did
these things visually and we did these
things over time and what we end up with
at the end of the day is so many
insights right I mean just in the short
amount of time that we've been looking
at this dataset look at all the things
that we've discovered right about one
insight per minute on average which is
pretty good and so I hope that you found
this talk interesting and I hope that
you've learned a few things today that
you can take back with you and implement
into your own workflow so thank you very
much for coming to my talk and here's
all my contact info and there's a link
at the bottom here to the code as well
if you're interested in that so please
reach out I would love to hear from you
thanks a lot
very nicely done thanks a lot for that
thank you
we have about 910 minutes for Q&A so if
anybody has any questions we'd like to
hear hands up somewhere I'll give you
the microphone all right right in the
middle I like it
hi so I guess I think this is really
cool but something that I'm kind of
confused about is how do you tie all of
these this I guess process into like a
like a prediction workflow where you're
trying to predict something in your day
yeah so the way that I usually do it is
I use some of the categories that we
created during the prep phases like
features let's say for like a machine
learning algorithm to learn off of and
sometimes that makes it easier versus
that having to figure out all the
continuous variables and that kind of
stuff there may also be ways that you
can change entities or instances that
you're feeding into the algorithm and at
let's say a higher hierarchical level
you may be able to predict more
accurately than kind of down at a more
granular so yeah those are just kind of
a couple ways that come to mind that you
can kind of implement this into a
predictive analytics process
I enjoyed the talk as well I thought
good work look really good I was curious
in your prep phase about with the data
you had it was pretty clean obviously
but in the real world and get a noisy
dirty data so I want to hear your
thoughts about quality assessment of the
data how do you judge whether the data
is even good enough to go any further in
your process of exploratory yeah also
clean up sort of approaches that you
found useful yeah so the data set that I
put up on the slide had kind of already
gone through cleaning phase there was a
lot more columns and like missing data
and all its kind of stuff so I clean
that up kind of for the purposes of
being able to present it and so that's
kind of one thing that you could do
right yeah like not not every aspect of
the framework is going to be applicable
to every innocent like if you don't have
time in the data you can't do any of the
time stuff right and so yeah just kind
of
depends on the cards that you're dealt
in terms of the data set that you're
working with how how deep into the
framework at how many things in the
framework you can actually apply to it
but at least with the framework you kind
of have a list of things and some check
boxes that you can check to say okay I'm
gonna start with this can I do this yes
or no if no then okay I'm gonna move on
to this step and then so forth and so on
so yeah what string over here okay I
have a quick question sure so let's say
you start with a bunch of source dirty
data bunch of it oh and the end goal is
to develop an enterprise data warehouse
how would you go through this data
profiling process go from bunch of
source data to find out what you've got
to clean it to end up with a good data
warehouse at the end yeah so going
through kind of this framework is gonna
really let you get to know your data
because of all the steps that you're
taking to it all the stuff that you're
taking with it know things that you're
doing with it
so each each step that you take is a
different kind of perspective on the
data so you learn a little bit more
about it when you're creating the
additional categories when you're doing
the clustering when you're taking a look
at it over time when you're at
aggregating it up all kinds of different
ways so I would use those to kind of
inform kind of how you end up putting
the data together if you're just
starting with like a huge mess of data
essentially is there a step in there
where you see where the dirty data is
and um shows up really nicely and
cleanly as there are the problems that
I've got well it's it's tough to answer
that question because each data set that
you encounter initially is gonna be
completely different from the next one
right and so yeah there's there's no
real like common way it's how you clean
the data up is just a matter of what's
wrong with the data to begin with right
and so yeah there's there's no real like
framework
I know specifically for like cleaning it
up let's say any other questions
so I found the different ways of
handling categorical data pretty
interesting
it looked like a really good idea to for
example a group all that out of
automatic in the manual transmissions
together that seems like something
though that's probably easier when you
have a smaller number of categories do
you have any rules of thumb or tips for
if you have more categories where it's
not as obvious that hey there's bunch it
has to happen to be automatic there's a
bunch to happen to be manual let's split
them up yeah there were some other
fields in the data that had a lot of
categories that we just couldn't do that
with right and so it's gonna really
depend on the meaning of the data in
that field in the categories in that
field in some cases they're gonna be
able to be F aggregated further and in
other cases like you're not going to be
able to know enough about each of the
categories to be able to do that and
that's just kind of a reality of of
having to work with data right how did
you come up with the edge weights um so
the edge weights were I joined so I
basically copied the table over and then
I joined on vehicle attributes and
wherever they matched however many per
each pair of auto manufacturers match
that was the edge weight so I think
that's all we have time for today I'd
like to get another round of applause
and gratitude for Tony already you very
much guys